Speaker 1: You guys know that any opportunity to
explain a an economics concept or a behavioral
economics concept, I welcome those opportunities
on the show and today I have that opportunity
thanks to an anti-vaccine leader who has
repented, an anti-vaccine leader who was
completely committed to their anti-vaccine
activism but has now changed their mind
and admits that the anti-vaxxers have deaths
on their consciences, if not on their hands.
This is a very interesting story, and there's
a lot to say about it. As Newsweek reports,
anti-vaccine Speaker Pasquale Baco repents
after one of his fans has died of COVID.
Unvaccinated, and we'll talk a little bit about
when it becomes personal. An Italian anti-vaccine
speaker has expressed remorse about his actions
after he discovered that a follower of his
who died of COVID had videos on his cell phone of
speeches that he made. Pasquale Baco is a doctor
who was a prominent anti-vax activist in Italy.
Taking part in numerous rallies and events
But now Baco, who has more than 7000 followers
on Facebook, said he was a believer in the
effectiveness of vaccines. When asked by the
interviewer what changed his mind, Bocaue talked
about an incident in which he saw a 29 year old
man die of COVID quote he had on his mobile phone.
The videos of my rallies at the demonstrations
of the unvaccinated, the family told me he was
a fan of mine. They didn't tell me with anger.
On the contrary, and this hurt me even more.
I feel like that death was my fault, and the thing
still bothers me today for it was not a creed.
When I saw the reality of my own eyes with my own
eyes, I realized that I was wrong. Asked whether
he felt guilty about his actions, Bocaue said, I
think that those of us who went up on those stages
have deaths on our conscience. All of us
anti-vaccine activists have been great cowards.
We went to the squares and when we spoke, we
knew that people wanted to hear shocking things.
So you provoke more and more. We were really big
bastards. I don't hide it. That's the truth. For
this, I have asked for forgiveness from everyone,
but that forgiveness is useful. He spoke at around
300 anti-vax protests and was the only young
doctor with experience. Among the speakers,
and he now recognizes the destructive
power of being a doctor at these events.
He said quote what I said was pure gold for people
who are afraid and looking for certainty. You
don't realize you were losing your rationality.
You lose your mind while being a rational person
at that moment. A dangerous process takes place
that anti-vax is a faith and you become a god.
You enter absolute madness. The anti-vaxxers are
people who are afraid and find security in you.
So many important things here. Number one. For
years, I have been talking about this phenomenon,
wherein part of what makes conspiracy theories
and conspiratorial thinking attractive is that
it provides certainty in an uncertain world
and that applies here, and I'll explain it
in very clear terms. Well, let me give
an analogy first, and then I'll explain
what this is. Why is it that to some people, it's
appealing when there is a horrible mass shooting
that kills 20 kids? I won't even say the name of
it, because then the video will get demonetized
or limited. There's a mass shooting and 20
kids die and some people come out and they say
it was a false flag planned event, with crisis
actors meant to create fear to justify taking
people's guns. Why? Why do they say that? Because
the truth is really scary. The truth is uncertain.
The truth is, kids are mostly safe in school,
but sometimes seemingly randomly. You might say,
Well, we're in Nebraska, so it won't happen here
or we're in Connecticut. It won't happen here.
Randomly, these horrible things happen and your
kid is killed. And that uncertainty is really
difficult for many people to accept. And so it's
more in a sense comforting to believe there is no
randomness here. This was a planned event. Now it
ignores that the event could be planned at your
kid's school or at someone else's school, but it
gives you a sense that there's not this random,
unpredictable nature to the world. Similarly,
it's really stressful to them to believe, well,
there's a virus and most people are OK, but a
bunch of people die in sometimes who dies is
unpredictable. Could it be me? Or maybe not. And
there's this vaccine, which it's mostly effective
at preventing people from dying. But it's a bell
curve distribution, and every once in a while,
there will be people who are fully vaccinated and
they die. So it's simpler to believe the vaccines
just don't work. They're evil tools. They are
meant to control people or microchip, or they
would rather that it's all planned. It's all
planned rather than vaccine probably will protect
you. But it might not. And the virus probably
won't kill you. But it might, and it could be your
parent or child or would. And that is exactly what
Pasquale Baco is picking up on here when he says
the certainty of the anti-vax stuff, particularly
hearing it from a doctor is so important now. Do
we like, forgive this guy? It doesn't even really
matter. I mean, it's not. It's not about forgiving
or whatever the case is. One other thing that's
at play here at play rather is don't fall prey to
the sunk cost fallacy. You're always better off
coming around and turning back to sanity. And
a lot of people like this guy because they feel
like I'm really committed to this anti-vax stuff.
I'm too far gone. I'm not turning around. You can
always come back and the sunk cost fallacy. Couple
of examples are you buy a ticket to a movie to
two hour movie, and after an hour and 15 minutes,
you're like, This is the worst movie I've ever
seen. But I already paid, so I might as well stay.
If you could better use those last 45 minutes
to do something more enjoyable than watch the
crappy movie you've paid for the ticket. Either
way, you shouldn't stay because you've already
sunk a cost into that movie. You get out and you
enjoy the last 45 minutes doing something else.
That's the sunk cost fallacy. Another
one is, you know, you go to a casino
and you lose 80 percent of your money and
you stop having fun, but you figure, Well,
I lost 80 percent of the money. I might as well
keep playing. Now you don't have to keep playing
and lose all of it. Just walk away and go,
do something that's more fun. So that's the
sunk cost fallacy. Good for Pasquale here. Not
falling for it and saying, as far gone as I am,
I'm going to turn around. And that's exactly
what he did, and, you know, I I'm not even
saying he should be forgiven or not, but.
Very interesting commentary from this guy.